ladies and gentlemen are we ready we
ready yeah ready with the great dove
David oh no no don't wear those socks
like that oh she's green socks the green
socks go with my pants slash gold two
different greens a little bit they also
go with your doctor's juice child's book
at home dr. Seuss hit him really hard
right yeah coming in hot
tough David off hearing everybody can in
San Francisco's in San Fran that's a
great club yeah no no it's a spot best
stuff David off what are you doing
what's going what's going on
ah life [ __ ] yeah well what are what are
we what our relationship stuff listen a
lot of things are going on I have a
major well what in terms of I'm this
professional stuff and personal stuff
and run all my own psychology in the
context of a relationship and you know
and then you have a kid and then you're
trying to build the building and then
you're trying to write a comedy and then
you're trying to you're trying to stay
on tie I mean this social media thing I
mean I've got such a learning curve now
I was I was [ __ ] yeah I mean but you
know but then again I would you had a
resistant LA and I went to build a
building I had a resistance a social
media dump dove is this guy right I
didn't have to do what I got I said I
said I'm gonna go back but I think there
was an arrogance to you know like doing
a TV show doing that I was like I didn't
need it but I should have it's a tool
that is very worthwhile if it's used
well and you guys use it really well I
just I feel like I just I don't uh you
know business I stayed doing stand-up
but I just wasn't on top of it you're
also not a TV right like crashing and
all yeah there's no two TV shows for
three years yeah back and forth crashing
what's the other crashing and the shades
of blue
Lopez yeah yeah yeah JLo in person yeah
no it's a good time but the best times
oh no no listen she she keeps it
together although that kind of drive at
you know at her age it's it's
conspicuous I think it's awesome
yeah but also chill at some point you
know just relax girl yeah get the cheeks
out hit the Sun you want
you want to stay relevant she always be
wrong you want to stay relevant let Joe
yeah I don't know I mean you know I
don't know I mean I think I I think
there's there's some value in achieving
a graceful irrelevance you know like
like if you got to be relevant and
you're putting it out there's one thing
you know eyes on the come-up yeah but at
some point if you have a few kids are
you gonna go fish never like that Kevin
Hart dock when he's icon be the first
billionaire and he's in like yeah yeah
sixty million dollar mansion in Bel Air
you're gonna be a billionaire he's
flying here doing I'm like no two beds
go home but no hope your kids do
billionaire for what yeah you have money
upon money your kids grandkids are set
for life you're right go home well I
think that he if you love stand-up like
I talked to Bill Burton he goes I'm
gonna be doing this till I'm a geriatric
which I'm it makes sense cuz standard
that challenge never goes away
yeah but that that they had ambition to
dominate that ambition to have that
comes from the brain the amygdala you
know that comes from all that needed to
control an environment because we were
dead in the forest ten thousand years
ago it's all the evolutionary but nobody
could make an argument that's making any
happier it's like hey I've got two or
three sandwiches it's all I can eat if
you had a hundred more sandwiches what
would that do
like no I mean it doesn't it's about
something else you avoid all those like
it's all you do to one in one
blockbuster movie therefore hey dude hey
dude leave me go home this guy's
handsome guys good with a smoke show
girl and we're we're just talking like
this and the guy stirs up he starts
talking loose because you're an actor
say my comment seems oh that's great
that's great and he starts talking to me
goes I have my MBA and I'm a surgeon so
you know that looks him goes oh you're
lost
he pulled the card out right yeah you
had all these problems were
some tough one
yeah I've heard it went wow I mean what
do I know like we all we all have you
know insecurities and drive is generally
good until it's now your that's not now
the best was you having the argument
with the CIA agent
the CIA agent talked about we're not
gonna make as much money and delicous
how much do you mean the guy goes as
much as I can make and dump that was it
after him and the guys kept this but he
didn't have any good answers yeah
exactly because after a while I mean
look all of the data associated with
with in all of the PhD studying
happiness is there are money correlates
up until a certain point if you can have
your kid educated you have some fun
looking for guys you know putting some
money into a race car like that's a
unique experience if you're just doing
it to acquire stuff to fill something
that isn't there it's clearly a hollow
pursuit and it clearly doesn't work as
evidenced by every psychologist you'd
ever want to talk to and or your own
anecdotal experiences for God's sake you
live in [ __ ] la how many douche bags
driving through dry to take it up you
got e4 with Sunoco yes anybody looking
no I don't know I do your kids still
talk to you you [ __ ] suck a fish
sorry no said sometimes I'm afraid I'm
going to end up yeah as that guy with a
shirt that's button down to low couple
of chains
I got a hooker in a convertible have a
nightmare that I would see I [ __ ]
things up with my ex and she was a good
person and I had a nightmare that I'd be
on one side of the street on Sunset
Strip over by the comics and then she'd
be on the other side of the street
except she's got a kid and a husband and
they're eating ice cream and they're
happy and it's and it's it's bright
there's sunlight and then on my side
it's raining and I'm just all wet and
I'm sitting there with Dom I ran and I
got an open chair Adan and I'm talking
to some chick about how I know people
with good coke like I want to be that
guy I'm gonna save my soul while the
getting's good
it's so [ __ ] easy to become that
you're a [ __ ] on that guy you're not
careful Oh God if you're not careful
yeah yeah yeah but anyway you know but
this is good what you guys have done is
is is excellent to build this thing from
the ground up it's great you know what
though it was like this we had Conor
McGregor on the podcast a long time ago
yeah and Brennan just goes looked at me
and he goes did you guys know that that
guy was
was he had the kindness when he was
already here oh you guys right he was
already was just in there he's like he
was about to fight I remember that why
he's about to fight he put it away right
after he got in into Jose Aldo's face
after the knockout of the Diego Diego
Brandao
oh you know it was after he beat up Chad
Mendes oh that's right so he was yes
he wasn't the the international
right-hander at that point he was banned
that was once he beat up Mendes that had
the wrestling question and then he
fought for a title yeah we got him in
between before he fought off yeah
Brandon said Brennan goes up you just
keep doing this is we're gonna do like
what he goes let me keep doing this see
this you just keep doing it yeah keep
moving yeah pod to podcast weakened
amount away all the time yeah yeah we've
basically done that I don't know how
many podcasts we've had but it's been
out yeah it's been six years man yeah
this one Wars - how many 528 yeah but
then how many how many do we have on I
was just told by somebody who knows that
we close out our - that our podcast
keeps growing and a lot of podcasts or
not and it's pretty wide right they
could do the fans well cuz you got two
grown men having wrestling that doesn't
hurt now if you want to go at it right
now you said the word you're working on
my second stripe on my white belt I'll
watch that oh go to his school you'll be
a black in two days on HBO crashing
anymore purple ball hey no I've heard
that yeah probably move people love
everybody in somebody's places no no I'm
just kidding not vegans not Higgins I
have a good day guys
it was a hot ten but I feel like there's
a lot of guys in New York besides Andrew
Schultz who just took this social media
and [ __ ] YouTube like a banshee
a lot of Newark guys are like okay oh
wait a sec a lot of they're not still do
you know yet is there an observation you
have about new because I don't know I
feel like the New York guys like all the
new york comics like the comics comics
all of them are kind of like social
media very new yorky thing i can just
look at i do not did a lot
yes I know when you have it's a great
like some of the greatest David tells
one of the great there's ever great yeah
he's the best
se7 he's won Olympic there's a genius
aspect yeah I know no I know there's
definitely younger guys Dan Soder mark
Normand Borgata yeah all like the big
boys over there but that's nice like
yeah yeah I don't want to deal with it I
know you wonder what it was not you know
New York though no Charlie uh no no it's
not just from New York it's that culture
I remember early on going into the
Comedy Cellar and I would check my
clothes so that Patrice Jim Norton and
David tell couldn't attack not David
tell Colin Quinn Patrice Jim no it it
like said no no but they kept it in such
a well verbally they would just look you
up and down be like you've shown your
eyes are too close together Patrice will
come I mean there would always be you
and they did well I didn't know him that
well but I know him well enough to know
that like anything you did it felt like
you were trying to sell some so it's
almost like if you think about music in
the 60s with nobody did commercials and
then you think about music you know in
the 80s or 90s or or now especially it's
not so bad to sort of monetize certain
things there was a culture I think where
any time you tried to push and market in
his sense that wasn't straight comedy
they those guys had a beef and I think
there's a residual aspect of that like
you know like like Jim Norton he's been
on radio front he's a huge he was
basically doing podcasting and his
stand-up and there's a reason why Jim so
big and Jim's such a good comedian Jim's
great him was one of the first one in
New York who how long has he been doing
radio
phenomenal a long time but they wouldn't
see radio as social media they would see
radio as radio yeah and so I yeah oh
yeah no no absolutely priests could have
been a great podcast no but listen
there's a wait look there's a way to do
it it's not going away if you're a core
if you're a horse-and-buggy builder you
know and Ford comes out at some point
you gotta go listen I've got to I've got
to I've got to incorporate the you were
the [ __ ] bastion engine you were the
[ __ ] guy the iPhone 5 was already out
six he calls Mary goes you know I got
this iPhone thing's great
yes well there and then if you know but
I had an arrogance right I had a bit of
an arrogance and I also had a couple of
bucks and I was also really involved at
that point I had an opportunity to go
and build you know the the
capitalization on this project is 17
million dollars it's not all mine
but we're building a project really
involved in that the idea come on hold
on to something that is sort of I didn't
know what it is that I'm who I'm talking
to or why I'm talking to them I do know
now and under Brian's tutelage oh wow
from their followers due to a lot more
left still a very small amount but it's
a resistance that I have if I didn't
know I know
I not only know like drilling it ya know
know like Brian come on I remember
talking to Brandon it was like yeah I
mean look there's a way to engage
without becoming a [ __ ] and so you're
always trying to walk that line unless
you're a certain level like Dave
Chappelle has zero social media friend
he was grandfathered in it's almost like
having a liquor license but he's a bad
but no YouTube all due respect along
tickets Chappell doesn't go on what did
tell you OSHA pel I think star Chappell
and rock no no none of them go on no I
think Dave Dave sold out Radio City Hall
about Dave Attell yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay I mean he'll go out with Jeff Ross
and those guys like he's crazy when they
do pumping but Jeff Ross is a beast on
social medias yes right so you post it
that's right but some of it it's like
when it's comics just like doing some
like goofy crowd work and then they post
a thumbnail like you're not gonna
believe what happened on this show I
know you know and that's just it's a
banner across and its clickbait like
like listen it is honor to be able to
find just thread that needle you got to
be able to mark it and say hey I'm here
I'm funny I'm gonna be at Cobbs come out
and at the same time I just don't we
come from a generation where you got
supposed to be a misfit you were not
supposed to be in your career because
stand-up was there in a lot of ways it
was a [ __ ] you to acting Stan it was
always that thing that was like where we
belong to a tiny you have so many
gatekeepers we belong to a tiny group
and and and yeah Sean Penn's awesome
come follow me some time [ __ ] it
was that
those yeah it was the anti comedy was
the anti career it was drunk drugs so
take a lot I like sad if you were into
Mickey Rourke or Sean Penn of those guys
imagine that guy going hey look what
happened in the front row he's got a
smile and a mic painted yeah zebra
stripes Daniel Tosh makes fun of it Tosh
makes fun of it like I remembered
someone asked him do his spot to do the
podcast and Tosh goes why would I do
that is whatever I do that is always
that is what I need to do for yeah he's
always been that way
but then he also on a show you know
he'll go he'll do like social media
humor like just poking fun ya know like
like the means and stuff like that's not
it the bottom line is that it's like a
great way it's a great way to have
control over how you are portrayed you
can use social media to be funny absent
and oh you're your own publicist it's
huge yes and yes yes there are some
people who got away with not doing it
because they got grandfathered in well
they're the big they don't stick around
yeah they don't know usually but I mean
sometimes if there's it depends on
what's going on and what they're trying
to sell but it's like what the [ __ ] you
look and I take my jacket off and you're
staring at these don't not go near
Brendan please no are you still boxing
though yeah yeah but how's your knee
he's not great but fine no no whoa
advantage my name um the I find that if
I get older as you want if your mix if
you doing some Jitsu and then striking
you keep like three and three I can't
days a week yeah yeah if you're banging
around a bag all the time we're getting
punched in it's it's um I find that the
injury stand you might know more about
fighting in terms of boxing and jujitsu
than any actor slash comedian I'm sure
that somebody knows more than me but I
know more than the average guy going hey
once coming McGregor hey remember Mike
Tyson yeah shut up
but you do know allow all the your true
boxing by yeah yeah no I stay on top of
all that yeah
even now you're I feel like I feel like
boxing had the as employee of Showtime
but I feel like they had the the Box
more by the nuts man when it was like
fury and Deonte and jaw and next night
yeah I know but yeah there's nowhere
near when I was yeah but they like
everything was the heavyweight division
was booming yet span Chet Crawford yeah
Canelo triple G like everything was just
yes like [ __ ] boxing they're better and
then now it's just like I don't know if
it to promote on to it man what well I
don't know what's going on with the zone
right I mean they they have those
fighters under contract that I don't
know what kind of fights they're making
I haven't seen a lot going on there they
spent 350 million dollars or something
on Canelo about it may not be able to
finance other guys highest highest
contractor volta yeah something like the
horse of like they have a lot having
shot at a time I mean seven fights in 15
minutes and there's probably a lost
clause in there or something they
probably don't continue to pay at that
scale if you're dropping fights I don't
know man I'm really sign it if yeah I
supposed to be guaranteed money but I
know you mean do zone was like alright
we have a switch business plan yeah we
forked out so much money man and in the
US the markets not it's just but they're
they they make bank on make sure go
right to get a lot of money on attention
Nationals yeah they're huge over and you
know yeah up and [ __ ] tissue or
something grab some yeah you know paper
towel um but I was doing a lot of blow
well yeah I felt like boxing like well
year ago year and a half two years ago
was Jeff Bowman man and then now it's
like like there's always an ebb and a
flow in boxing whereas it seems like in
MMA like they're consistently putting
out competitive fights cuz give me the
fight you want but they're giving a
fight you're ducking guy in control that
hasn't I mean yeah like you know
everyone's like oh you have seized
monopoly it's like yeah but it's the NFL
of mixed martial artists were the
biggest draws in at the UFC though the
biggest draws I mean there's so many but
there aren't so there are low but the
point is is in boxing like Earl Spence
and Crawford Crawford should fight but
they have to do so you basically have
one guy helping UFC they're never gonna
there never
I've listened the charlo brothers have
been on but the beating everybody for a
long time that Tony Harrison fight I
thought was great nobody was like I know
but they not able to communicate it to
the public in such a way I couldn't find
anybody to talk about it where I know
trials are so talented man did inaudible
and they're great and but they're not
fighting anybody than anybody knows
neither one of them that's not Canelo
one Canelo fight that's why I've Canelo
number one pound for pound one because
everyone's safe Crawford and spans like
no they're not fighting anybody
Canelo's actually fighting dudes and now
they can race different weight classes
call the left listen they don't go there
Mike okay tell me the last guy Terence
Crawford beef last guy Spencer yes
that's right Randy beat Mike Garcia
smaller make your tier but still and
Crawford is over at Bob Arum is over it
at Arabs company they're not you're not
just amen
and every time I talk to you like I was
talking a Brian guy who was a you know
used to train and Mayweather's camp and
all and he was like he thought it was
Arum and then other people say that it's
um it's why am i blanking on his name
the other promoter in boxing no no
there's only one other huge guy who's uh
controls this disown there's arimin than
this PBC yeah
anyway it's it's all jammed up it so
it's just weird men and it's also like
we're like with Joshua yeah and the ruie
stuff the al Haman yeah
so there's Joshua and the Rhys tough
right and then he beats through a reason
like well let's run it back 1/3 times
like no that's over - no I know right
the winner of fury Wilder what are you
three doing of course what you owe it to
us what are you guys doing can't Joshua
do that can't he can't do anything he
can't he go because whatever Herta he
does whatever [ __ ] at her and says
but Eddie her and he could who was was
it Dana while she's also making all the
money though because he made what 80
million to beat up [ __ ] of fat and
Erie's you know but if you're not it's
when we go here's 80 like alright I
don't keep going and how are we
promoting the next generation of drawers
if every fight I think I'm using Dana
White's language would he said every
fight in boxing is a
going-out-of-business sale they're
grabbing all the ticket dollars they can
and then on the main card you could be
watching an undercard you could be
watching a co-main that's excellent I
mean every now and then they'll bow to
God it's very rare that
go from the only reason anybody buys a
pay-per-view list why is the watch the
the main it's it's you know what the
laughs well build a scalable business
the last card that was like stacked and
pure boxing aficionados yeah but it was
when Logan Paul ksi that was your main
event which got all these eyeballs but
that the undercard was your [ __ ]
stacked Billy Joe Saunders yet that
Garcia kid I know that hanging out like
there's all the younger good talent like
Billy just on doing tremendous hopefully
kids Canela night see that you know
they're just understand with that would
that happen oh yeah they were they're
talking about a dad be slowly assigning
don't have this talent to do it man what
and nobody wants to fight that guy no
right over here yeah I mean here's the
problem he when he fought on the he was
the co-main event on the logan paul kids
i you father guy no one really knew his
like he's coming out party me finding
eyeballs were gonna translate a they
were show off on that but yeah she
didn't look great so in Canelo's cage
side yeah yeah and he's not a knockout
guy have you seen so understand i god
he's so nice Lemieux oh my god yeah you
still a blur Lemieux was a banger of
frightening eyes water but here's what
matter looking you beam you imagine
being with me walking around Montreal
but here's where boxing's at is is the
zone had to go let's get this youtuber
Logan Paul who I love I he's a good dude
I don't people I love Logan Paul he's
what do you love about he's actually
good person he's beat the game okay for
what he's doing I don't know you know a
twenty who I don't have any he's 23
minutes forty million dollars year yeah
yeah hey you want but yeah here's the
thing though he didn't have to take that
box in it but my thing is with the zone
this were boxing that they have canal oh
they have triple G Ollis but they have
to use Logan Paul celebrity to book up
and sell fight and then put legit boxes
underneath I don't think that's
sustainable of course not that's the
[ __ ] you know what do you so do you the
way you know that you get the best
fighters to fight each other
dick you gotta have the best fighters
just like the UFC is doing but then also
if you want to live in that logo
Paul ksi world you you create a card of
all YouTube fights which they have so
many subscribers and all that that
thing's gonna sell like crazy
hello that you also do a pure boxing one
yeah but don't mix look let me ask you
this isn't that young fanbase ain't
watching the TV show social media
there's some whether you follow this but
the UFC it was holding that huge note so
who bought it william yeah that big four
billion dollar note or something like
that - boo - billion something like that
and i think the issue is how do we were
not we're not making enough money to
service this debt the pay-per-view model
correct but then yes paint came out well
okay and they and they bail him out they
had the biggest year they've ever had
you can made the most money they've ever
made last year that sounds nice a big
year
so uh but now that now they don't care
about your pay-per-view they don't they
don't care that well it's a different
model right i mean they want you to
order it that's all that used to do but
now they have the bump for ESPN is the
subscribers and so if they don't solve
that many pay-per-views it's still
inferior win but they say no matter what
they made they made a deal to the
guaranteed money so yeah thanks for the
draws the drugs you have c mosfet all
right now still Nate Diaz definitely
Conor McGregor of course khabib draw
yeah huge Tony Ferguson for short but is
that dannis Tony against one guy well
babe everybody everyone that you just
listed is only big if their parts
partnered with the right person right
that's not should be Conor
so the UFC doesn't in between but the
weather in here they're not in the
business of making
blockbuster Marvel movies they don't
care
why doesn't covers it or not they did
shine put on good fight pride you want
there you go that's good fight and then
the big Conor fights they look at what's
that what that's done for the product
right Dana white tomorrow I mean the
brilliant that Brooke I don't know if
it's brilliant but we every other sport
you watch no it's definitely brilliant
but with the point I was making was that
every other sport the objective is to
put on competitive competition so that
that and so if you lose it's okay I
still want to see you play the game
again correct in boxing if you're not
you know you can't garner any goddamn
leverage in the business which is an
awful business model we can't match you
up in any competitive you know exciting
fights until you're a guy that means
something money-wise and then that whole
relationship between champion and
contender and how much like you you're
not seeing all these young fighters in
competitive situations and then in LA
but they don't care if you have eight
losses on your record attend loss on
your record if you're an exciting
fighter I want to watch Mike Perry fight
every time if I watched on Cerrone fight
I was loved why if you fought tomorrow I
watch them tomorrow night I'd watch him
I don't give a [ __ ] I know and then but
I'll say about UFC but yeah 100%
were you in boxing you're killing it a
guy gets out pointed and then we don't
see him again against anybody
competitive why they don't figure it out
though because we all know this and they
have numbers Garcia fought on Showtime
you guys know that you fought some
random Russia I tip here's the problem
read catch I've been fresh catch tough
guy good guy good guy know what I know I
have one watch and he didn't knock him
out Jared hurt was on the under car he
didn't yes who's a stunt yeah champion
he well he's coming back he's coming
back right here's the thing is uh Danny
ties in law Danny Garcia yeah you lost
Danny Garcia didn't get up like great
performance so then it's like alright
well what do you do
I know and he's against a tough guy and
but the fact that every time you step in
the ring you got it you got to twist
somebody's head around like The Exorcist
it's like in order to garner any
attention from the public like there has
to never you know I know I know and
canal is exciting the guy he's the best
but the but boxing if every if boxing is
contingent upon one dude what happens
when when you know who is no you mean
Floyd Mayweather yeah well no even
though isn't there talk of limit they're
coming out of retirement finite vital
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] out he would never
like that he will get devoid of 50 or
whatever the way of Floyd's in his
forties and he'll get killed by he'll
get email her he would never do think
you're right not to your right and he's
sharing only Rivero Spence what doesn't
want a box any bhai level but I think
Callen started this rumor that the old
hammer is inviting Connor or Mozilla
[ __ ] not fighting real boxes yeah
right you can box an MMA news room right
oh my god yeah but man you got to
remember when did he fight Floyd Canelo
lost the floor Canelo is couldn't you
wouldn't you've said thinking about stop
this you wouldn't you Sinn féin Brian
you're out alive you would have said the
same thing about who fought in through
his 50s Hopkins yeah yeah yeah right no
no no that's not true but not have to
know how I'm his fight level guys yeah
all the way here up until the end Floyd
has been out of high-level competition
for years right you can't come back and
fight yeah for Pacquiao six seven years
ago right yeah less than that well maybe
it's a bad it's a bad stop yes but he's
never lost yeah you know looks like you
know an amateur when he fought yeah that
was like team when they fought he the
reason you know I did it understands he
knew he was like really young isn't
gonna be the next thing what everybody
but he chose you chose well it's the
same thing style banners doing with John
Jones stop it yeah yeah yeah they
offered me the fight a year ago I'm
right I'm went from you get older yeah
my young ass and beat his ass right yeah
he was it's a Canelo Floyd thing okay
yeah which is a shame I would have loved
to see him fight Pacquiao when Pacquiao
was at is at its zenith you know what
he's not telling everybody I know it is
i nuts that's my knocks in a nutshell
you don't have Dana wait wait how long
yeah that's and that's the five years
after past it you get it you get you get
you get exactly what you want that's
what's great about do you see yeah I
love it yeah I can't but that's why I
can't gold is not I can't wait see
Connor Maslin all they're not gonna
fight you think they're gonna fight
Brandon I mean you know better than I do
I mean I'm just running I'll tell you
what I don't think I've elapsed it I
don't think that Connors fighting could
be max that's insane to even discuss
that's right they're not kebede has to
fight Tony Ferguson yeah April yeah
there's gonna be a massive war that's
not a gimme on Connor and one thing
Connor doesn't do he doesn't lie so he
goes hey I'm be active share it's the
honor of fighting Caesar
you'll find three times this year so if
you just go based off that
he's not next yes there has to be
someone there whether it h e-- whether
it's maas of it all that would be next
I'm sorry she's frightening do I get a
show time go but that gate that gates
he's frightening right um and and look
I'm not saying Connor couldn't do a
Connery I guess could beat anybody at
fifty-five in theory except for compete
but gauge he's a frightening guy he's a
weird guy to fight he's a weird guy uses
his wrestling be different buddy just
sits there and slugs with Connor I think
gets lit up yeah yeah yeah yeah no no
maybe I mean maybe that's the fight to
make but don't you think Maz Vidal like
it'd be a CMOS but all because because
even if you were to lose a Mazda he's a
bigger guy yeah yeah Astro 55 in the
it's tough to say I said I was a small
seventy you know he's he's a little
small for seventy and he's mommy's of
all he's a [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] he's never been tapped
every even even the fights he loses
awkwardly fought like Jamie Maya who did
he get he's not his backup no no exactly
Demian Maia had his back defended all
that like high-level every he's a dog
he's an easy dog but I mean he's not
just a dog like yeah geez like he seems
high-level everywhere he goes
I remember his defense in the Maya fight
my heading right back dude my head is
[ __ ] he had his back he had his back
yeah insane yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
tough to shake Maya off
I gotta start taking my job I think the
I think the remember he has his back in
a triangle the rep oh no it was that
kymaro's so all's ask tomorrow's when
the refs stopped them and it's separate
oh yeah yeah yeah
how was loose and I was nervous on him
he was on Rogan tomorrow I found my food
truck
great guy great [ __ ] that one of the
best yeah phenomenal dude
phenomenal dude at Kevin Leon Kevin Lee
we can't can Maas but I'll beat him
that's a good fight it's good fight
right and they've trained you know they
think they've trained together all those
Florida guys gonna be come on to be
honest man he's a mother [ __ ] look at
him his fight you saw what he got the
Woodley but his fight with Colby
Cummington
and Kobes oh my god always a killer I
don't know man that's he's come cause of
the real deal he doesn't seem to get
tired either I mean I don't know
gonna beat them is why the top of 70 is
exciting yeah you know this is our boot
besides light heavyweight and
heavyweight the weight classes are in
the UFC yeah there is miss yeah
boom-boom yeah it's [ __ ] but it's
never been better
yeah in any weight class it's never been
better
it's so violent ya know it's a it's a
good time it's good to be a heart fan at
55 in a 70 in 85
it's not smokin offski surprised me too
that was a surprising fight when he beat
max Holloway like that he beat him
convincingly have you ever seen Volvo
knopf ski when he's like 250 260 pounds
crazy rugby putting crazy yeah what oh
yeah he dropped he was 80 90 pounds boy
yeah I'd heard that and I thought they
were I don't know his nature how kind of
yeah hold on
yeah look at that it's crazy he's like
240 doc yeah well it's funny he looks
like the beefcake oh yeah he's a
beefcake yeah he's such a stud comes
from the same campus style bender jesus
[ __ ] christ him hooker look at his
face there oh god what a nightmare
but think about me back right I saw you
would know better than anybody in this
room but what do you have to overcome
that that that differential in reach and
sighs Holly yeah man that's a [ __ ]
tall order I've sees max Holloway yeah
but you [ __ ] with a high kick leg kicks
at five six I know but he's not the
first guy that have thought of that game
plan nobody else has been able to do it
knows really
it's his camp man let's not those now
Ben and the boys yeah yeah oh and what
about Romero what about that fight um I
think it's not been estar Chisholm think
so nobody's done it yet yeah but look
what he did a Whitaker I thought oh yeah
I thought that was a tough match your
stop enter stylistically I'm a cop yeah
for when I see this winner I don't know
whicker's explosive yeah when it moves
when I was I was with Kelvin Gastelum at
the Comedy Store
last Hill he's there last night the
other day and and I was like sitting
there and talking and I was look talk
about overachiever then I was out happy
father I am than he is I looked at him
and we always do this but no but I mean
but sobbing r64
stop energy everybody is
there's a Kelton sorry is there did it
makes no sense he's he's he's that good
I mean he's eating a 70 pound her I mean
there are guys that were cooked a 55
with that with that for I mean and he's
tremendous at 85 I'm 55 is a stretch but
70 yeah I mean you gotta believe that
he's he's got a 70 pound frame 100% and
he's the best guy you should be a
middleweight no yes no he's too small
right here right here's the prop but
here's the thing he's so goddamn good so
good that so he's you know he was one
round away that thing was it now by turf
at UFC fights ago yeah yes yeah look at
his diet and stuff like that if you know
but sink to DC every was I really should
be at 85 or you know Roy Nelson really
give you 85 it's like I mean yeah I want
to live his life completely miserable
you live normal and that in tell me got
some so goddam counted yeah he'll
probably be champion someday if I had to
bet on one guy yeah and there are just
size anomalies like that a guy like DC
you're right yeah obviously he's able to
make 205 but get there until
good-looking I'm seeing Darren till yeah
yeah yeah yeah he was working so much
though he was too much he walks into 201
he's in that deal yeah I know what he
looked like but that's a good example
somebody who looks like an 85 er it
looks like you cut too far down to seven
oh he's perfectly yeah and at 85 it
looks good he's another guy probably
gonna be champion someday oh yeah he's
oh he's a young he's 26 or something
like that chrissake yeah get it
everything yeah yeah yep yep I'm gonna
do that next time I wait I wanna have my
have my hands high like that I like I
like beer things like that we have no
that's a funny well he always does it
but yeah but there's not I mean even if
you have my pie like yeah it's fun it's
no pugilistic it's like you know yeah
yeah like a John L Sullivan pose or
something hot and cold what he's being
clubbed no I can't do no some water
again hey what do you think of urea
water remit very wild every match is in
February you gotta love the fact that
that that Wilder just it's he's he's
everybody's got to be perfect against
them for
for ultimate off to all 12-round
literally can't yeah you go to sleep
everybody's got to be you know I mean
I'm exaggerating when I say buddy's got
I am a harder puncher what's that name
harder puncher in the history of the
heavyweight division I can't people go
Mike Tyson at know Sam the tar-baby
Langford 1787 no um but he is a real
fighter by the way saying the time maybe
Lankford a great name but as far as like
straighter Joe Walsh ah yeah no no no
nobody chambers but I had a different
crazy power style than this yeah yeah
but it like this yeah well yeah you
remember yeah in this fight as and Tyson
Fury is a better boxer but know if one
is quiet down the fight knocked him down
twice we won the fight yeah he loved
that he lost the fight he won every
round he got dropped in two rounds you
couldn't tell you do the math that b3r a
lost three random let's call if anyone
tries it doesn't how is it how is it how
I think he's got it IIIi think they call
it a draw because ii knock out knock
down was was so so the fact that he got
up here's the promise and here's my
problem with that and i i'd you know he
got knocked down and he almost killed
fury here's what's crazy here he got
back guy no and what but uh well boxed I
know you didn't win the round buddy he
got back up and out crazy box you know
it's crazy so it's like I guess that's a
10-8 yeah I think you're gonna sir won
that fight I fear we generally won the
fight if we're scoring off yeah boxing
rules yeah everyone the play yeah and
judging from the war nothing for my
ropes and the environment they were
boxing judging from the gloves and the
ropes I thought we were scoring off
blocks in holes but apparently the
judges didn't do that but a guy like
wild it was strange I don't think
anybody's gonna realize how good he is
until right now when you see not only is
rank better - he keeps being able to put
guys away that he shouldn't be able to
put away Ortiz was a killer that bent
Cuban he just fought he didn't have to
take that fight hated it John's like I
hate this funny you don't follow about
you don't realize how dangerous that
fight was wild almost got knocked out in
the first for Tommy Ford did he was
losing lose on the cards going the tenth
you can outclass you get us
southpaw huben from that school I mean
granted the guy could be 50 nobody never
9005 he's a [ __ ] yeah it's how I
want to see this one's a killer it's not
gonna happen because the promotional
reasons but I'd love to see injuries Jr
yeah well I would like it to anybody
yeah that's kid such a fun fighter to
watch you can't help but root for the
guy and by the way he's a good fighter
or did you have a seat or not know any
movies jr. oh yeah and Erie students you
see I saw I saw Evander Holyfield being
interviewed about sparring um Andy Ruiz
jr. and he goes he's he's so fast he
just talked about how good he was he
goes you don't want to fight Freddie
Roach Fred Freddie Roach it when they
made the announcement auntie Joshua any
Ruiz on the short notice
yeah there's Freddie Roach azan rectum
like I don't like this Fanti Josh gates
in here his hands are fast
yeah it's inside it's on yeah yeah over
like jaw and he can and he could get
inside yeah yeah he's everyone hated it
like come on down yeah 25 looking like
that 36 months every 36 passing you am
mad what are you doing you had a you had
a shot it's called self-sabotage
it's called self-sabotage that's what's
called shock I call it [ __ ] the pie
dough you gotta be money you got to be
careful with money and doing that money
I wonder if it hurts as many people self
as a champion that's what it is I think
sometimes you have to do you have to
think of your several anybody one the
freyal that believes he's you in the
first fight but then he also yeah sounds
like 301 amateur did you don't matter
real pro oh yeah he's a real pro oh and
by the way he fought parkour like he
beat everybody ever fought except for
Parker Joseph Parker with Joseph Parker
who's the stuff that outpoint did who's
his stud it's not like that guys just
scrub people just saw him no no no no
don't let the shitty body but the
insiders knew that guy could fight he
invite I I just think I don't think it's
not here think you was didn't thing he
was a champ I just think he just you
know got Faton happen it was like I know
it's a champion I'm good
it's the Buster Douglas syndrome when he
got back in the ring yeah it is it is I
mean work with this if people keep
saying it's the buster no the winger's
doesn't work with the Buster Douglas cuz
you know Buster it was kind of like that
that fight you know Buster Douglas [ __ ]
Tyson up you remember with Antares jr.
and NC Josh oh the first fight it was
the fight every Sunni got knocked down
yeah goddamn that regards ground never
guard it was just as far as becoming up
Douglas got hit in that fight you're
still a good fight no no he didn't get
dropped what I expected was anyways come
in thinner and better [ __ ] yes this is
the shot of his life to really prove
that that wasn't a fluke I had a lot of
energies a lot of birdies I wanted him
to win and I kept quiet I was on Roman
ruins like hey I think it's a chance
went right in so many people going dude
he's here he's doing this yeah yeah
that's right and that's why I guarantee
you Joshua wins this fight gentie yeah
you know our boy Todd oh he's bets on it
put as much money as you can on Joshua
huh
you never get you can't beat him yeah
just wish Joshua would it would have
gotten more aggressive in the second
half see I don't mind it man I don't
like him meet with Joshua there's so
much on the line his Chris oh I know
nice jab good footwork and I'm like
waking bak because then when I see that
I go alright that water fights a little
different Grand Island he beats water
but a little in right fight yeah and you
forget he's a gold medalist in the
Olympics he can box you know he said it
today I mean he's a hot guy right those
guys I want to see Joshua fight fury and
I want to see ya Wilder I really do
that's the fight that I just don't want
I want him to take more risks you know
that's what I love about a guy like you
know Connor McClane oh wait so he's
saying that about McGregor but you love
guys that they don't just win you know
he could have gone in here's the thing
though like we should we [ __ ] on
everybody does it really especially
they're not in England everybody sits on
don't fight discomfort if you look at as
far as like no Jews walk some who he's
fought compared a Wilder fury it doesn't
compare got off the frame and Tory
switch go be clear I mean you look at
his eyes compared to these other guys
much better yeah much better
no no he's he's it but over here on the
snakes are like [ __ ] I'm like there you
got ya but you gotta look into it man
well cuz people see you get beat by and
you
Jr unless you're a real fight fan you
don't know that a guy that looks like
that can still be real good and so it's
hard for them to imagine it I want to be
built like that yeah good law such a
good body it's such who has the better
body him or Walder I say him him for
sure right it's too long too long yeah
he's - I don't like kind of weird
enclosed Josh was the dimepiece fighter
in the kid okay a porn edition okay yeah
mom yeah no you're right though
yeah wow there's real lucky which is
another amazing thing with that kind of
power but I hear the physics even posit
make sense his face he dreads his foots
off the ground everything nothing makes
it from it's from other shots but as
soon as it touch it's game over game
over
that's a dirty part in the world crazy
like his heels art like there's no here
PE looks
he doesn't look coordinates like even
guys that just started fighting I mean
you have all not just start a few years
ago still look good and then crazy
that's a Teddy Atlas god yes yeah do you
some of the longest life yeah guys I
don't know man I gotta get some tats - I
gotta get serious you gotta get serious
we'll get that fight up in reality
that's boxing well but see here's the
thing they could both fight each other
they could just say I want to fight nope
contracts Brian God do it I'll do it
hell they can't dude but come on that's
like you beyond a year on ABC yeah yeah
and then HBO yeah oh don't do it Brian
let's say let's say you have but they
were in contracts right they were in
they were having contract well they were
doing discussion right so if they're in
discussions it means it could happen now
it's just a numbers game no there's so
much that goes into it do you talk about
two different promoters the amount of
money and their clients a good
promotional out if the amount of money
those promoters can make I know you'd
think that your will against a long game
go right it's anti job so you can fight
and II worries my face alignment will
make a hundred and fifty million dollars
gotta lay some more gold next we're
gonna keep going keep going and that
won't get this at the back
so otherwise let's take our job so it
goes in there yes starts by Walter yeah
what do we do what do you do you do the
remap no yeah of course so you got a
goat you got a goose with golden eggs
you keep the golden eggs you keep it's
the worst thing because if imagine doing
this forever when the mob ran by it's
been doing this forever and then and it
still has a life people are passionate
about it
but if they don't if they aren't able to
get promoters to work together and adopt
that model we didn't have MMA we didn't
have the UFC fifty years ago when they
were doing this or something is you
forgetting this to do boxing generals
are older sport men I know it is an AI
kids not into buying nothing
eysan MMA it's all there's more out Nick
most kids are in the UFC
yeah younger generation I ain't [ __ ]
with box I know so they're accepting I'm
less you're in Mexican less they start
getting cooler they're rating you like
this yeah yeah I know I go right now
she's better at marketing yeah is your
app yes more fights funner fight from
Yvonne or looking people personalities
women men yeah sexiest ring windows are
sexy ass [ __ ] you know fighters yeah
yeah yeah you got the cost of it you got
all these bad how much drop is it when
women are coming headlining is there do
you know I don't you know what the
discrepancy it I don't know I don't
watch it I don't know I mean if you're
not Ron it's gotta be a drop I mean I
went to last you know happen star rate
oh oh you took in my boxing no open
those the bots in the juice oh yeah
there's never boxing there's Clarissa
Shields is you know she's such a stud
but yeah of course but nobody's no
common flashing against the [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah we like to have like a
young cyborg or something um yeah it's a
good time yeah Rachel also by far the
baddest on the roster well there's some
other ones whoa what's that I don't know
she's a fighter
[ __ ] it's going on there these aren't
UFC you just running hot hottest female
yeah okay God but to old list to but
there's some in Bellator there's some
other ones in UFC they're just
ridiculous she's well she's one who her
boyfriends are nuts
yeah I'm not
yeah I knew nothing I seen the guy's
head everybody's coming down on the guy
everybody relax
I'm half at you I can give the guy you
know you go to prison you get caught up
with some guys every now and then gotta
you know one of the leaders of the Aryan
Brotherhood was had with half Jew
everybody calm down
so not everyone relax let's all calm
down sometimes you got to survive in
jail you know Jessica guy goes to prison
he tries to fit in suddenly everybody's
down on him you're gonna figure it out
getting a couple of tattoos
he'll exhaust ads yeah it's a good time
I know I caused the screeching apart so
what else is going on relationships
housing kid holds the kid old 40 months
four days you know he's 14 months yeah
he's on who'sa no it's Boston now ten
weeks 14 months oh wow yeah yeah YUM
yeah no it's great I mean I don't know I
did the marriage thing is I'm I don't
know who does a marriages I mean there
are some people that do I you know we we
call them homosexual um no I'm hittin
your [ __ ] snowflakes um there are
people that don't believe that they I
know guys that are you know that our
hapless how many people do you know that
are happily married just curious Evans
none if you're gonna try to pressure
test my idea push me over there you know
you know I don't know anybody know that
I've met a few people that's that claims
you're happily married right but buddy
it's always tricky man I think it's just
always tricky any con any time you're a
really we're not built for it listen you
can argue that it's the best vessel with
which to move through this existence
with but you can't argue that that it's
it's natural and so it's always going I
think it's natural to have a study home
and like mother of your child yeah
monogamous anything even in the animal
kingdom with that well outside of
penguins and a couple of other birds I
mean nothing monogamy is not natural I'm
not saying don't do it and I'm not
saying it's it's not the best um of
course if you want to have children and
a traditional family you can make an
argument for that but it's clearly not
natural which is why everybody struggles
with it yeah wait no I mean it is fact
yeah everyone struggles with it
and then eventually guys just get just
like right well this is there's also the
question is also the question you see
and they're just like I know but you had
a glassy submission in your eyes it was
pays like watching you tap you know but
but it's a the people don't talk about
like the price of optionality
optionality meaning the idea that you
have a lot of options like when people
talk about money money's overrated after
a certain point it's overrated let's get
awesome
that's it does you have money though no
it's not I've been in place where I had
no money no no no I don't mean it's not
better than being poor I mean having a
billion is not better than having a
hundred million it's meaningless that
differential is just about power ego and
something else you're not gonna live
anybody and I can eat anybody you're not
gonna have any better health care your
kids aren't gonna be any more a decent
private you um and there might be less
less decent at that level there's a lot
of actual statistical data this is on
the upper end 100% they're gonna be kind
of four hundred percent kids most more
like you have a drug dealer you've got
suicide there you go come from a
billionaire family yes Christ so it's
your honor according that metric then
it's overrated right I'm not saying I
would never be as presumptuous to say
like um like people that don't have any
with you're struggling to pay bills
money's a tremendous problem solver
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about people being obsessed with
going
it's another forty million or he's
making forty who gives a [ __ ] yeah after
difference between listen I eat as well
a bit like wow so you got a private how
many times can you do that you still
it's called the law of diminishing
returns all of these statistics are very
clear in terms of people's lives but the
optionality for a guy like you or a guy
like you in terms of women means that
you're gonna struggle that much more
with monogamy than somebody who doesn't
have that option ality in which case
it'll create more anxiety and a lower
likelihood of success in terms of
monogamy so it's some for some guys it's
not that much of a struggle
here's it here's the other thing though
I'm a nice guy like name any famous
person when they like Oh blah bol I got
caught cheating on their wife or a girl
and you see society like the regular
Jews like
oh yeah what do you mean what the [ __ ]
yeah dude you take one step in that man
shoe when he flies into a city I've seen
30 smoke shows I mean have their tits
out iiiii had been around when I was
young here's the job why into Chris Hart
joke the Chris Rock joke is yeah you
know the girls know yeah yeah guys like
damn only three
yeah yeah right right you know I was
with David Blaine when we're both young
and we went and Mark Messier member Mark
Messier he'd just won the Stanley Cup
yeah yeah he and this other famous
hockey player were hanging out and they
were in the prime of their lives and I
didn't know who he was I just don't love
this thing you know how you know how to
love this angle here this hole this you
know it's I'm trying should be should
anyway dial this in a little bit better
I mean this yeah you're right apart
awkward let's get it - [ __ ] you together
here we should what we should do is get
a smaller couch and angle it this way I
think so no I look at Bryan I'm looking
at this when I go when I he's gonna fix
like a breakdown we're bring it down
here fix that fix that goddamn it
sometimes you want to listen to
something interesting Brennan you want
to listen to something interesting you
want to enter something when you're
driving yeah did you talk about we
crashed on one 'dry yeah I am you talk
about we crash on wondering I'm talking
about we crash you tell Matt we in one
fast on one dree I'm trying but we crash
time yeah you're talking about dude
you're talking about a company a little
company called
we work all right we're a host David
Browne digs in what happened between we
works initial 47 billion dollar
valuation to Adam Newman being forced to
pull the stocks IPO
he resigns a CEO and watch the
shareholders value nosedive in 40 days
yep guys think about that Scott Galloway
serves as a key adviser
dude remember it had 15,000 employees a
private jet and stood poised to become
the world's first trillionaire with we
work or so he thought no no that ain't
happening all right yeah that ain't
happening he said he wanted to rent
office spaces he said it would change
the world
groupthink and a cult of personality
allowed Newman to be God
initial investors conflict of interest
mismanagement losses soon and investors
Callixtus excessive we work despite a
desperate desire to crown the next tech
unicorn you want to know more dude be
you ready for their I wanna say it's the
largest destruction shareholder value
since Enron ham you want to hear more
you like what job don't miss January
29th premier of wonder ease we crashed
on Apple podcasts you can learn about
this insane event this insane seismic
business default if you will where so
many people lost money smart get too
much over faster reads over all right
fine you want focus you want your mood
to be optimized you want your digestive
how you want to mix things up dove you
and I talk about mixing things up you
want to mix things up make sure diet up
man exercise I'm alpha brain get some
Musco nutrients some key minerals
alright performance about your immune
system come on let's go on krill oil
joint oil maybe you need to work out on
the road maybe you're expiring comic or
you are a comic you're on the road all
the time you can't go to the gym maybe
your son man how about we got workouts
on demand on your phone you do in your
hotel room from your living room at your
home whatever you want they got body
weight on it six workouts on at 6
kettlebell on at 6 steel mace string
fitness no more excuses to be a thick
kid on it calms last fighter temper sent
off its your one-stop shop to fitness an
optimization I apologize I came down on
you guys what do I know you guys are
running a successful podcast then I'm
better I got 13 followers on on on on
honest you remember I've never seen the
kind of women I'm not I'm not kidding I
was the young man I've ever seen the
kind of women that were around him when
I was a young dude and I and I I didn't
I'd never it was the smoke show some of
the smoke shows right they were all
around and that one in the New York
Rangers we're going I mean I was just
like I was like yeah that helps in women
I've ever seen in my [ __ ] life I've
never seen if anybody's around that okay
it's overwhelmed right but so as it
relates to that bright I mean what are
the happiness coral it's like you look
at those things you go yeah it's the
dream of a teenager the problem is when
you get out there if you are trying to
maintain
a family and a wife that kind of
situation actually could create more
anxiety and more unhappiness than it
generates and so it's wonderful up until
a certain point it's a fine than lined
up to find [ __ ] line I'm telling you
everything that glitters is not gold
it's a very fine line I am very very far
nobody's figured it out you either
single either age one hold on name one
LeBron James has been married to the
same woman like that Brandon ha he's
been married to the same woman for a
long time right dude and I happen to
believe there she is how so wait so but
just the premise being what what you
saying he's the premise being that he
doesn't [ __ ] around ever at all or it's
that or that he doesn't experience
anxiety when I don't trying to a not
[ __ ] around no idea all right we'll have
we brought it I'm sure some men are
wired differently in some area yeah name
one I don't know anyone that we know
well it's likeliest leo flowers joke
about nobody has five Super Bowl rings
or three Super Bowl rings for Ferrari is
one girlfriend right yeah I don't know I
don't know I don't know how that works
I don't know see that's the change to
because they're not those people like in
the open relationships like well that
ain't the way ether no I know there's no
no no no there's no not the way our
buddy Aubrey was early do you you're so
stressed yeah so what is I and then he
goes oh we're gonna have kids we're
gonna raise the Vigilant don't do that
please stop that don't do that dude well
here's the answer my brother lives on 26
acres in Massachusetts he's married to
another psychologist your attractive
ladies and Duncan yeah yeah and so and
so the answer I for a guy like him is to
stay centered he doesn't live in the
middle of Los Angeles so there's a
logistical component in this cuz it
consideration there's nobody there's a
bear that lives by him that really
diminishes the likelihood of struggling
with
to move to the middle of Montana you
guys gotta get the [ __ ] out of here he
would know well hold on there a couple
things I mean that so it's not the age
of generates kind of figure out monogamy
my dog has an opinion about nuclear
physics yeah but here's the thing if
you're in a relationship here's what
happens to a lot of relationships I've
noticed marriage they get in a
relationship they're doing their thing
they're monogamous and then they get
bored of each other for yeah sure yeah
they just get bored of each other nice
to sexually been a lot of way forward on
my car to myself without without but how
do you introduce adventure but that's
human another thing how you do bring
[Applause]
people in as a group I don't have an
answer wear a mask and [ __ ] other people
Brian who's invited you in are I just
invited you laugh do you bring wear a
mask it [ __ ] do you bring people in
that's what everybody's really trying to
get to the what do you do I mean you
bring guys you know you've got a tall
dark and handsome guy with a nice [ __ ]
do you bring them in hey by the way do
you blow him are you bored a baguette
doesn't make me gay I'm just looking for
excitement why are you a sexual
communist thing even a rots sick of
[ __ ] Jake is JLo from behind I will
guarantee you I love my crowd there's
not a better car I truly bliss on the
planet than that g21 did you do you long
whereas I'm used to it yeah I'm used to
it all right he has no I mean my g2r no
unless we don't want it's the best
[ __ ] private reality real engineering
the other right buckle fun I've been
[ __ ] that car behind for three months
listen to me it's called the law here
that you're already I'm not sick I love
it but you're already used I love you
got used to it ain't nothing but your
regular I dunno ice cream
to me everyday philosophical phrase for
that is the law of diminishing returns
it is inescapable it's an inescapable
law everyone says so you do met you
meditate it's human nature there's no
there's no way around it right the law
of diminishing but what's your therapist
say duh when I fairest have you talked
about it he says why don't you bring
another guys no no I have talked yeah
absolutely you know my PI know the age
I've talked that there were new
appreciation the process enter yeah the
probably the third the problem with the
therapist is you're talking to a
six-year-old do no it's not no it's not
you they're younger my mother psycho
[ __ ] there are my brother
psychologist and you don't need to
experience something to understand its
effect psychologically no it's
presumption with that well you just said
a 60 year old therapist if you got a
younger therapist or no no even I think
even a six year old therapist can go
look I understand it must be very
exciting to bang new tail to get in that
car to go out you got a big [ __ ] but
it's like to do that must be exciting so
I think of good analysts would say yes
all of that's exciting then you have to
identify an objective it's like talking
with Coach it's like it's the same way
anywhere wheeze went off the rails right
it's like there's a way to renew
commitment to some sort of if that's the
objective but it's always gonna be a
struggle it will never be easy to come
in in top shape the [ __ ] ongoing it's
almost get hockey after a while to if
you watch boxing trainers are like well
we'll see if he comes in and shakes okay
the whole job is coming in each in one
job I'll go with doing it that's your
one job it's not gonna be any hold on
you so it's also like deciding that the
bottom line is that you at you get a lot
out of my mind you get out you get
monogamy and that relates you can write
you can get a lot out of elbows but then
you got is it it's just fit you get a
lot I a minivan you gotta win this for
cash she's recently single this is the
talk we're doing it we're waiting wait
you are you recently single
yeah I didn't know that but you bring
everything do you all the tactic yeah
a party you like ask my guys to sleep
with guys while sleeping with you I got
a piss out of my huge dick I'll be red
yeah no there's no carry on yeah but
you're also in the thick of it here I
mean look if all of those um those
options and that anxiety you're in this
you're in the eye of the hurricane here
is the eye the comple I don't know if I
use that phrase right but you're in a
hurricane no the but the eye of the
hurricane is pretty relaxing you know
right okay so you're not in the eye
you're in the actual swirling part of
the hurricane in Los Angeles at your age
with you all of that like more rounded
sharks with tip that's the perfect storm
that's that's the perfect storm it's
like all of those components to make you
crazy about that [ __ ]
I would imagine like if somebody is all
old or old enough and not in the center
you just it you still think about it but
you're just just less there's less
anxiety yeah if you yeah if you talk to
uh you know any the guys you know my
peers who are all think it does you
comics and they're like you know it's
not worth it like this just not worth it
the juice ain't worth the squeeze man no
you know that what's out for P and yet
everybody still struggles with it that's
the human nature part of it like you
know it but that's the difference being
like when you think about I don't know
if it's a if there's a fight analogy in
it but there's there's knowing when to
do something yeah and then there's just
doing it like the concept like everybody
knows to show up in shape but you have
to have so many other things in your
life dialed in in order to show up at
your best and so whether it's Conor in
his last fight or Andy Ruiz in his
second fight like you see guys that just
couldn't keep it together when they
weren't or even when they were gym
Roberto Durant's whole career was like
that in and out he gained 60 pounds
between fights and eat everything [ __ ]
everybody and knock out a horse and then
we started when he tried to dial it down
yeah we love that guy yeah we love that
guy who's more fun than watching that
guy Johnny Tapia was smoking crack in
between fights again I don't mind a
killer killer and you love that big
Tapia rooms hot and collar keys finest
Albuquerque's fine Johnny Tapia wasn't
murder we were talking about heating he
was smoking crack between
I mean he had big coke problem and he
was between fighters and I feel and
still a world champ there's a
documentary on him vvvv - loco me Vita
loco it's great oh yeah Johnny Tapia is
tremendous life they're gonna make I
think a movie about I don't know plays a
guy like there he is watch Johnny Tapia
my rocks playing Johnny tapa oh you know
speaking of the rock you know what what
is there ever enough
is there ever enough that did that you
go maybe I'm gonna dial down the need to
sell something today is it ever enough
that's what I say all the time I
disguise in Palma you know somebody told
me so I've been doing it in my informal
study of like people
it's literally like it's always all this
pot hey man hey and then it's a hey buy
my tequila hey these are my shoes Hey
after a while I feel like [ __ ] you
you're a fake yeah it's like I'm sure
you're a great guy and I probably would
have a different tone if he were right
here but I would still say the same
thing imma go
when's it enough yeah hate to kill this
is matter I never know I never got a
word I'm signing this never know what
it's my thing when's it enough guys go
home but go home [ __ ] it home after what
this is like it's the promotion never
[ __ ] in France I mean it's just like
at what point do you and then the movie
promotion and then the tequila promotion
and then you tie in all the promotions
it's like a Tony Hawk man I mean he made
60 million dollar who gives up for a
walk in Atlanta what you know you were
at Peter Thiel's house Jill's got more
money than that guy lives in a
three-bedroom house he's not obsessed
with the money yes with doing [ __ ] he's
boring he's not trying to sell you
[ __ ] tequila while selling you things
but bothering those guys like George
Clooney you don't see all up in your
face with a dick in tequila stuff and he
sold all that he's like I'm good man
well the amount involved with a piece of
a company and he would see this as not a
an an Integra like a life that's
associated with some regard for there's
a kind of integrity that isn't that but
you just every [ __ ] thing is a sale
it's weird well and he seems like a
great guy he's also a great well he's
but I'm sure I've heard him talk he
always seems like he gives a [ __ ] gonna
cool and he cares that good he's great
but whether the thing is also the amount
of he's good at drugs that he's the
amount of extra steroids a he taking but
what don't we all know this yeah I hope
so
but I mean some people like how muscular
do you need to get here it's a very so
that's this thing right yeah a superhero
in all the movies laughter there's you
can't you cannot not but ten years ago
he was just he was awesome to his MA his
body looked fantastic don't get as big
you look at the ideas that you need to
be that big right well I'm saying his
career it's exploded because he's that
guy you play her yeah right nobody who
how many other people can play that guy
Hercules I usually he just had a great
sense of humor he was a giant guy who
could oh yeah absolutely yeah yeah now I
feel like he's overdoing it I feel like
he's just not sure why yeah like he's
just so veiny until some good movies and
that's a lot that's a lot of veins it's
always this you know when you're coming
up and you try to gain attention you're
trying to get some leverage in the
business you're coming at things you're
doing what you can a guy like that like
how much how much how much you now
you're selling me [ __ ] tequila you
saw me 13 movies in the last two months
now at the Keela hey Ashton the fair
consume in Columbus Ohio this Friday
spectrum CBD the best on them gonna
start with this weekend buy your tickets
for tomorrow Friday and Saturday you're
taking off but that's different in it
like what from what a comic does or like
that what we do here it's it's different
than you're also not the rock if you
made 13 billion dollar grossing movies
and then you're trying to come out idea
oh my hold on you know hold so it comes
to be and Brian goes hey men yeah here's
I yes race goes hey you find a kid will
give you Brian each ten million right
there's no social media give my dates on
the spot I don't have a phone that's
right sir I might be gone yeah I'll be
like Bruce Wayne you said me zoom I
far from you and I would take off yeah
you would never see me a good social
media by your car I'm taking back to New
York
oh yeah you love that car I like that
could you see it done first you're a
real reason I mean II do you see other
people to invite guys and what do you
know to mix it up in a relationship yeah
the guys I don't want to see my really
get [ __ ] by some spice it up like
watch him a girl gift [ __ ] now that you
bring up maybe a bottle if you want me
to do that brand wait ask you know
what's going on all right bring up bring
up let's do some current events that's
current events with dub Davidoff yeah
and Brendan Schaub Bryan Callen I'm
uncomfortable with what do you got with
promoting this cobb state coming Friday
Saturday in San Francisco Mighty Ducks
okay so this was submitted by Richard
Stacy so this guy used to be on richard
stacy is a fan we do fan submitted yeah
alright so keep submitting this is a guy
who arrested for breaking into
somebody's garage he actually broke
their front windshield and then he was
found sitting in the car they later
found out that he used to be an actor he
used to be on Disney Channel's um oh
yeah
yeah well I know he's in the movies yeah
he's in the movie yeah my it was either
go fat kid go yes yes you don't put your
children in acting class is that the
point yeah yeah yeah I uh
what is he / was on Ellen yesterday I
guess he has some new document' you come
now yeah I need to yeah it is on YouTube
yeah who's it come out
I believe it's already out in every week
they'll release a new episode so they
talked about her because he suffers from
well at least he's skinny enough but
here's the thing she saw but the diver
was talking about does it matter she's
13 and doing like these sold-out shows
he suffers from depression
jitties on or whatever and he was saying
how he did all this like extensive
research it's in the documentary and his
dopamine at 13 doing just performing
private lanes and getting this in this
his dopamine at that age and then when
it just drops when he shown up and drops
it [ __ ] with a kid's face Kenneth jam
his chemistry gets so [ __ ] up so when
as he gets older that don't mean just it
doesn't come back because yeah and it
became like born again it's always
getting weird but it but it but they're
learning that young kid through a real
famous with that dopamine release that
really [ __ ] with the chemicals in their
body so that's why it suffers from
depression yeah
damn yeah and that's interesting that I
mean it does kind of it also why we
don't dial down the kind of things that
we involve ourselves in you can go out
look and you know you get guys going
bring some other people I know but
you've also come other women I know but
we could bring some why not bring a
couple of guys guys the cut you put
words in my mouth you sons of [ __ ]
no I don't usually think about it like I
don't mean just and it happens with I
think it happens with that that happens
with the fighters oh yeah dad certain
fights I like it guys come on man let's
go and it's like well how many guys come
back when they shouldn't how many boxers
have a good life could go off on into
the sunset but that's that thing that's
that thing that it's that money doesn't
scratch it it's that pomp it's almost
like a canopy with terminal chasing the
tail of the ball of addiction well same
thing with criminals same thing anybody
wants to do stand-up comics I mean
criminals yes parla prose read about
when you're on the road for a long time
I don't know if you guys ever
experienced this but you're on the road
and you're alone all day you'll just
alone and then if you especially have
your own real damn people then you hit
it with you have all this attention yeah
and
then you're alone in a hotel room or yet
what do you do go to the library at noon
you're gonna go train then when you're
in Columbus you've got now after a while
the Broads don't spike if they don't
they don't spike the endorphins like
they used to get the bros juice that's
awesome I got Justin Bieber disease why
not spice it up now that time that is a
you know that that's why they say be
careful what you wish I did it they did
it they've done very really interesting
study on the double helix of how a
serial killer is created yeah and one of
the things that they'll [ __ ] tell you
is that a serial killer exactly the same
thing they start with like a fetish then
they'll start killing animals were and
they have to keep upping the ante oh
yeah and one of the things about that
psychology is once you go to the next
level you never go back you can never go
back you can ever dial it down because
you can't get the same rush once you
bring a guy into the room then no girl
because you were looking for a good time
but was all about sex now I live in West
Hollywood and then you didn't then
that's not enough so you have to kill
him because you're chilly so there you
got a drink I love blood you gotta come
a dictator yeah then you gotta go yeah
no there's no man here at gay Dex
genealogy that's the theme of this show
cause should be called gay Dexter yeah
be careful what you wish okay so we
talked about this guy before this is the
guy from fire festival that went viral
because he said that he was willing to
suck dick for the Evian water to be
released he actually just got a
sponsorship with Evian and they're
starting to release specifically made
bottles that says Evian
so good you would do anything for it Wow
Wow
so he's he's officially a spokesperson
for Evian hilarious it's good on Evian
for being funny that's my favorite water
you're right bet on him before uh now
what he's willing to do for a boy no he
was right festival they needed water and
he had to go talk to the town council
guy oh he said whatever was the guy who
was okay in the water yeah I was ready
to get on my knees and to suck his [ __ ]
right yeah and cuz because the guy goes
if you I don't care if you have to suck
his [ __ ] and he goes well I was gonna
suck his [ __ ] for the water yeah he was
dead soldier that's a soldier so if I
move in with a guy why is all this Evian
stocking up their friend when I got 32
bottles of Evian three guys on the couch
what happened I don't know I'm a big fan
of eviant hmm that's right I remember I
had there was a girl who I she worked
this was 13 years ago
14 15 years ago and she said I was
driving and she was
to drive me around and for a job and it
was a it was a commercial job and she
said I don't consider [ __ ] to be sex
right oh [ __ ] like shaking the hand and
I went yeah and I went huh I go what do
you mean because this is just something
I love to do to please whoever yeah like
dogs but oh and I was like ah like if
they're under stress in science you go
see especially and I go under stress
Cruz suckish she was driving a shitty
car turns me on more [ __ ] and she had a
thing hanging from the yeah she had for
the story of sex it may not have been
but it was something she had a red bore
a Coke or something she didn't eat well
and she had and I was like I forget no
no she was cute she was cute janda but
but what you'd call tacky makeup tacky
makeup that other girls like she's tachy
and trashy and you go well that's Molly
like yeah I like dragged up in her mouth
that's right and then so I go well what
about over there and she goes there and
I go sure I feel like I could relieve
stress right there Taco Bell parked on a
hill it may as well been had sex no taco
Park Bell Park parking lot with her she
kept her feet up bring your feet down
yeah see yeah as I bring your feet down
and you see the movies come on she was a
great kid
yeah and kicking her feet but she had a
bus on still I go oh your feet that I
can't bring her feet my feet down
against get kick him out so one after
another is a big problem either way we
didn't get caught and I didn't care and
then but I remember that she pulled over
and now that was that and she sucked
yeah sure didn't she really enjoyed it
too a girl
yeah and my stress was she's still
around she probably isn't I don't know
she probably died of shame I don't know
what happened I don't think he had came
to begin with yeah you know what so
original about Brian is he was in a car
with a girl who said I don't consider
[ __ ] sex which is the same things are
going I'm gonna suck you off right now
Brian's first thought was she probably
doesn't eat so healthy probably doesn't
eat that have you been drinking water
drinking what's up with the red book you
want to suck my [ __ ] well you gonna get
rid of the shoulder I get a pretty good
Red Bull are you gonna [ __ ] can we
get that soda out of the truck before
you shock me exactly can I get you
involved in vitamin C before you go
before you suck me off to take a
multivitamin okay I'm gonna let you do
your promise we can take a multi viola
fication to service [ __ ] okay
so after the Grammys lizzo through an
after-party at the strip club crazy girl
strip club here in LA and she bought out
the whole place so her and a bunch of
her friends can go and party after the
Grammys okay there's a video analytics
there's a video of dually pas throwing
money at a strip pass to Aleppo and a
lot of people were upset with her saying
that that wasn't feminist and so now the
train to cancel her this one here yeah I
hate people a lot of people are coming
to her defense that they're mad cuz she
so she do dollar bills at a stripper
yeah do they realize that's how
strippers make a living yeah and they
think this is against the women's
movement it's weird because they say
it's anti-feminist anti-feminist of her
to do that but you also shouldn't
stigmatize sex workers so it doesn't
make sense
stigma tahadia stigmatized Simmons got
their ass it can't be that big of a
movement I love this okay this is cancer
culture is eating its own tail it's such
a [ __ ] yeah yeah I don't and this is
like what maybe to the 20 because they
really damaged careers what you're
saying is right there aren't that many
yes unless unless unless yes maybe less
and less and the careers they've damaged
yeah kind of deserve that yeah well a
lot of the ones that were thinking about
fine but this is a flash yeah no this
would be okay but I think there are guys
in companies that you don't always hear
about I think a lot of people have been
damaged maybe in ways that we haven't
heard about you're right listen
Bill Cosby brought on my honor on
himself he but he's not
and above a me-too thing where his CK
got jammed up in a bad way he's not
cancelled and we'll all that be fine
no he's gonna be fine don't you have a
shine yes yeah but he had 13 different
things going on that he worked years on
they got ripped out from under him so I
mean ah she's so [ __ ] bad but here's
the Fiat yeah yeah no but you're right
you're right it's gonna happen laughs I
would hope it makes a lot of money but
the thing with Louie CK it's like oh you
know and everyone's up in arms I mean he
didn't rape anybody
you know and you just join up for a
peoples like hey dude you can't do that
right I think you should lose all is of
course shouldn't not every some
repercussions but he doesn't affirmative
he does take heed for even showing up at
comedy clubs at this point no no no no
what Enquirer or hey what you could sell
it entirely yeah yeah he's good no he'll
never be Comedy Cellar at the Comedy
Cellar they gave gnome-like has their
people riding in from there was a big
social media thing but they wrote in
saying we can't believe you put him back
on at the claws a while ago though right
if you want to say improv like right
before I was there and they're like oh
the show sold out oh no I'm not saying
I'm not saying he's not selling Joe's
yeah and as they go were there any
problems I think yeah the problem was we
didn't have enough yeah we didn't have
sense yeah go with their protest yes no
no II were just mad with it yeah see ya
and you're sure they don't give our Fox
anastasia's yeah the world doesn't give
up their world doesn't give Lucy
Kenwright yeah well what's the price you
should pay these are not bad you know
public companies care so if you're
looking to get a movie financed you'll
care if you're talking about selling
tickets you're a hundred percent right
yeah I'll buy a ticket see him like I
mean I think everybody else will too
now he actually raped a girl yeah man
yeah totally yeah no no I'm slacking off
from fasting that there's a yeah even
Heinlein yeah do you know um do you know
Louis pretty well uh well I wouldn't say
well but certainly I've sat at the table
with him a number of times and he's a
thoughtful I mean in my experience
sweet brilliant definitely brilliant
yeah high level talent and you can't
tell a guy like that he was one of the
you guys really doing original work
whether or not you thought the show was
funny or whatever like personal it was
some it was a high level [ __ ] that he's
up to he's also Mexican yeah a half
Mexican right yeah yeah I don't know
yeah he's like half Mexican half you're
like Eastern Europeans from Hungarians
huh well CK I thought was like it was
one of those one of those leaders yes
pal like it was like if you think about
like a Hungarian newsreel ke wz or
something like what is Mexican though I
don't know what it really is but it was
definitely there you got this Wow that's
why you shorten it to CK says yeah you
just wouldn't know how to exactly Wow
fifty-two years old I don't know
interesting yeah I got you guys talking
about monogamy
sure so this soccer there's a soccer
game I'm sure you guys heard about this
guy ready oh yeah dude I haven't I know
I don't know what did you so this guy
that he was on the big Jumbotron yeah so
watch this is during the broadcast he
sees himself on the big the jumbotron
and then he takes his arm off any guilt
oh no oh no this guy's got jammed up so
that was a side piece oh you do not want
to be him on his way home is your
[ __ ] side piece of the game um but
this is how he explained himself - right
here he's Spanish
right yes a woman was in my place what
would you do various circuit of
unfaithful women but they haven't been
made fun of as much as me I hope you'll
never have to be in my position
Hey and my time defending my honor and
my pride as a man until the end we all
fail and we all repaired thank you for
those who have invited me to church and
if I got it so I can kill my family it's
okay no it's going to be able to damage
my image god is big and strong and these
women who are criticizing me I know to
have cheated but they still comment it's
your problem not that guy - already
destroyed my relationship what more do
you want
hey listen yeah he got on
turned it into the eulogy for a
bullfight that's what you don't know the
second leg of the journal damage you
have this genius with your hatred
directed at me yes everyone fails and we
can't forgive from our God give me
strength that span spans like they're
all like a the president has so much
like they do this yes yeah yeah that's
why they take that but France want me to
wrong who is the fact that he was
president for 12 years or longer he had
out of Spain he had his his mistress was
that as you know right yeah yeah yes yes
yes yeah yeah I mean that was the French
president and France knew it and France
didn't say nothing about monogamy yeah I
mean the Italians the Spanish the French
you think he was bringing guys in the
[ __ ] bride yeah you get Brower who
has it the ice who is the president of
[ __ ] ah my lingerie run away to create
spice some people you know maybe take
yohimbe room some people bring in
ethnics Oh hit me rude hold on who was
the guy who was the president Italy that
the really flamboyant one he had orgies
I mean he mo you doesn't a bellows
colony barrows corny yeah hey yeah
mother [ __ ] it up
oh the plastic surgery and he [ __ ] yeah
know that who was the girl who he was
banging she was literally oh you gotta
see her she's gotta said though I don't
know what she was only one there was one
that they got it was like you know he's
your brother but we felt that too like
JFK was [ __ ] man
Oh Trump [ __ ] yeah yeah 24 hours if they
didn't have 2400 Trump yeah Trump [ __ ]
Trump look at har that's on say but JFK
JFK wasn't there was no big thing made
about it he was banging a lot non
yeah yeah hey look holy [ __ ] she's
delicious he has a whole slew I had war
jeez well you got a [ __ ] up you got acid
he's the most powerful man in Italy [ __ ]
Italy they just kind of go come on
awesome I mean but he has no mafia ties
buster yeah right bouncers are soon to
come yeah yeah oh yeah don't we think of
Brian get some uh some [ __ ] done on this
Brian looks great he doesn't need any be
talking about you're not getting any he
makes fun of me tells me I got a slinky
neck son of a [ __ ]
listen we're all getting older you know
I'm not I'm not winning any awards are
you all doing max the Brennan and I had
no you did I'm a heterosexual know what
you mean a roshani because otherwise
Brendan would just put you on your back
and and spice it up as you would say hey
when did you spice it up when you had
him pick a mask on ya bunch of guys all
bunched up out of my favorites that guy
was like poking uh what do you do like
you could he did he just beat the [ __ ]
out of it I go which one your friends
asks it I go
none but they were questioning what the
actual [ __ ] a guy trained a little I go
hey look at me go you're gonna hate when
I say this to you yeah Brennan could
[ __ ] you oh yeah or nothing you're gonna
do about it yeah no but does he not know
that guy should have here a friend guys
don't like to hear it you guys don't
like these I should be your friend why
do I give it's in my head you wanna see
us real quick and then on this yeah sure
well you did some [ __ ] because I need
your help my favor I treat you like
you're joggin I'm not a jock I'm sure
you [ __ ] dude you're my job don't touch
my hand
[Applause]
this is not
just nothing well this is nothing that's
good stuff that's fun that's good stuff
that's good stuff it's good stuff that's
good stuff that's that's that's what
would that's what we quite got a train
more Cleveland
this weekend I'm sure I'm teaching a
seminar how to fight bigger guys
tomorrow Friday Saturday yes West Palm
Beach let's get some tickets I don't
know what's Palm Beach tomorrow
no no West Palm Beach I'm there a
Valentine's Day weekend February 14
vacancies I'll be sorry tomorrow
Cleveland hilarities Cleveland Saturday
thank you for these bring your mask yes
you're a cha you're at Cobbs Cobbs and
not Chavez jobs I'll be a judge if he
wants to spice it up I will be a little
bit one of the best comics Cobb San
Francisco thank you guys for having me
thank you thank you I'm in Columbus Ohio
Friday Saturday next week San Antonio
Thursday Friday Saturday then
Valentine's Day weekend Ontario
California get you some Vancouver we
undertake it's left VOC theater just for
last Comedy Tour de fat K comm dove
we appreciate brother let's mix it up
you guys just a fun kid we're out